hi my name is jacob scott thomas
bertrand and i play hawk
hi i am mary mauser and i play samantha
larusso hey i'm peyton list and i play
torrey
i'm shola monitoena and i play miguel
diaz from cobra kai
today we are with buzzfeed to take a
quiz to find out if we're more
cobra kai or miyagido
first choose the word that best
describes you
our options are loyal kind
supportive brave ambitious and
reliable i think right off the bat i'm
gonna have to go with ambitious
i think i wouldn't consider myself brave
i can cross that one right off
the bat what about you guys what are you
guys thinking i think supportive
i mean like i want to say loyal
definitely not reliable i'm late to
everything
don't invite me anywhere like i might
not show up i'm terrible but like
supportive i feel like i could do
i'm thinking supportive too i would
probably say brave i was gonna do
ambitious but
you can just say that i have the best
answers it's not a problem jacob now
pick your biggest weakness this is like
gonna get so personal for all of us
to start crying right i get too
emotionally attached
i'm a little selfish i trust you easily
i'm kind of stubborn i'm a bit bossy
can i only choose one yeah
multiple choice to be fair like i feel
like insecurity definitely is like the
thing that holds me back
but boy do i ever trust too easily
i'm also stubborn as hell i mean all
right i'm just gonna go with
insecure because like let's be honest i
get too emotionally attached or i trust
too easily
i went with stubborn yeah you're
stubborn i'm gonna say i trust you
easily
i think i'm stubborn yeah we we all
think so too
yeah i'm so i'm so glad i don't have to
work with these two
all the time like you do feelings mutual
don't worry
kai character you trust with a secret
sam
miguel hawk tory aisha or robbie and i
would have to go with aisha
because i feel like she was a great
friend to tori and i also feel like
she's super trustworthy and
i would trust her the most what are you
guys i feel like there's so many bad
answers
like but no way in hell would i tell
that man
honestly i would totally say miguel
that's true i'm gonna go with robbie i
trust robbie i trust that robbie
has no one to tell i chose myself
there's no one that i can trust
better than myself all right you can't
trust nobody out here
everyone's kissing each other and
everyone's going behind each other's
backs and backstabbing and i can only
trust myself
choose a badass fictional character to
fight alongside
wonder woman katniss everdeen from the
hunger games adonis creed from creed
john mcclane from die hard uh beatrix
keto from
kill bill and black panther i'm gonna
say adonis creed right off of that
wonder woman and katniss are awesome and
beatrix they're all fighting ladies but
like
yes we all want michael b jordan mary we
know
it's okay i'll be honest about it i want
to say black panther i was about to say
i think i would go with black panther
too
i'm going to beatrix from kill bill i
just watched that movie again and when
she takes out the 88 the crazy 88s or
whatever it is
that's an insane scene i would want her
on my side all right let's see how would
you spend your ideal friday night
at a party with my friends date night
with my significant other
inviting my closest friends over to have
a chill night in
kind of a weird okay
having a nice homemade dinner with my
family practicing because there are no
days off
duh or by myself watching my favorite tv
series i'm not gonna lie i read the
having a nice
homemade dinner and having a nice
homicide
it's like a nice homicide with my family
okay i think
even with the weird till day that that
was entered in there i think inviting my
closest friends over to have a chill
night in is something that definitely
during quarantine
that that i'm doing more than anything
i'm gonna go with the same i'm gonna say
date night
date night with your significant other
i'm doing
the closest friends i just think that's
the most realistic pick an 80s movie to
reboot
the breakfast club beverly hills cop
back to the future
heathers do the right thing or the
goonies i feel like heather's kind of
got
like a reboot in the sense of the
musical so i feel like i'm i'm gonna
take with the breakfast club i'm gonna
have to go with heathers for sure
i love that movie beverly hills cop i
really love yeah i'm deciding between
beverly hills cop and the goonies
i feel like the goonies deserves it more
so weird way to freeze that damn
you just don't deserve it finally choose
something important from cobra kai
hawk's tattoo all valley karate
tournament
miguel skeleton costume mr miyagi's
medal of honor
bonsai trees or johnny's coors banquet
i think for me it's johnny's quartz
banquet i think if there's anything more
synonymous
with the show it's johnny and his beer
i agree as much as i want to say hawk's
tattoo i gotta do
johnny's beer it's the show you know you
guys are a bunch of cobra guys i'm
picking miyagi's medal of honor because
technically that's
the thing that started the whole season
to fight if you go far enough back
well i mean technically what started the
fight is uh your inability to walk down
a hill without having to hold someone's
hand but i mean
[Music]
mark determined and stronger than all
miyagi dose
please tell me that's not actually
what's written that's really what's
right it says you're stronger than all
the miyagi does that would be the most
something to say you are 100 miyagi-do
you're brave level-headed and resilient
you're very in tune with your emotions
because they're usually what motivate
your actions
i think there was never there was never
a doubt in my mind
i was questioning peyton because i like
i feel like knowing peyton
in real life like you're such a like
nice person i i
was not expecting the more cutthroat
answers no she's pretty mean he bonded
last season
and we went out and we had a lot of fun
so
she knows me well apparently
[Music]
you